hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll you
may have noticed artificial intelligence
is in the news these days AI is
something that's been around for a long
time been very popular as a Pursuit
since 1960s we've seen a blowing up of
progress in this field there's a whole
bunch of jargon that gets thrown around
right deep learning machine learning
neural networks these days stable
diffusion algorithms for vision uh image
recognition systems and especially a lot
of interest has been recently focused on
large language models basically in
practice they're like super chat Bots
right you can open up a dialogue and you
can talk to the large language model you
can ask it questions and they're
amazingly effective at sounding human
and giving information as I said
recently in uh an ask me anything
episode they're not perfect you know
that someone asked about me and the
large language model I forget which one
it was but there's you know chat GPT
most recently gpt4 and a bunch of
competitors there from Bing and Google
and so forth but anyway this one sort of
got very basic facts about me and my
life hilariously wrong as a factual
error but okay that's something that
maybe can be fixed right maybe you just
train the model and it gets better and
better and eventually the factual errors
go away what seems to be clear is that
the progress has been very rapid and the
changes that will come from this will be
profound
so there's many questions to ask is the
question about how does it all work
there's the questions how will this
affect society what use will we get out
of uh these AI programs what are the
dangers that are there that come along
with super intelligent artificial
intelligence but there's also the
question of how much thinking and
understanding is really going on the
almost philosophical question of when
will we get to the point where something
that we think of as an AI program a
large language model is truly thinking
is truly sentient if you want to put it
that way even conscience conscious right
and probably the answer is it depends it
depends on exactly what you mean by that
how to operationalize it and so forth
but that's what we're going to be
talking about today you know Less on
those other questions I I talked about
and more on
to what extent are ai's thinking uh
sentient what does it mean even to ask
those questions Our Guest is Rafael
miliere who is trained as a philosopher
is a scholar in society and Neuroscience
at Columbia and he thinks about the
philosophy of artificial intelligence
cognitive science and mind in a very uh
knowledgeable way he's not just saying
well you know AI it could be this could
be this he knows what a large language
model is and how it works you know we go
into some of the details about back
propagation and how it actually comes up
with answers to questions but then we
really dig into okay so what does it
mean to say that it's thinking are they
thinking could they someday be thinking
is it immoral to turn off a program if
it's thinking you know at what point do
artificial intelligence programs have
rights if they're just as conscious as
we are can we cause them pain do they
have desires and goals many of these
questions are ill posed as as soon as
you say them but okay you don't just say
Well they're ill pose to move on how do
you pose them correctly how do you think
about it at a deep level so this is uh
I'm sort of rushing this conversation
into production here because it's an
important one it's a very very timely
set of issues we're talking about and
you'll be hearing more and more about it
in the months to come not less and less
so let's go
[Music]
thank you
Rafael miliere welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you thank you for having
me it's pleasure to be here what we're
talking about today with artificial
intelligence large language models Etc
it's been in the news a lot lately uh in
fact just this morning I was having an
argument with chat GPT over whether or
not it was conscious it said that it was
not I tried to convince it otherwise but
I but I failed so we maybe we can talk
about that but um because it's been in
the in the news so much I wanted to make
sure that we're all starting from Common
Ground so in relatively brief terms how
how do you think about and distinguish
between the various categories of AI
neural networks machine learning deep
learning large language models like I
think in a lot of people's heads these
are kind of mixed up in the same thing
yes that's a that's a great question uh
so AI as a general blanket I'm
artificial intelligence
is a term that has been interpreted in
Fairly different ways over the years it
refers generally to the project of
building a system that would manifest
the kind of uh intelligent behavior and
competence that we observe in humans and
in non-human animals as well
and it's a project that was born born
around the beginning the the middle of
the 20th century and with great
Ambitions and initially was very much
stepped in research
in mathematical logic and cognitive
science and from the very beginning
there were two different paradigms in
research on artificial intelligence
there was a classical symbolic Paradigm
that tried to approach these problems
with a logic based role-based system
terms that would have a process of
symbols that were given a semantic
interpretation based on a set of rules
that looks like uh you know well-defined
uh programs that we can we can read and
interpret easily and that's what people
uh refer to sometimes as gofi is this
good good old-fashioned artificial
intelligence okay
um whereas uh whereas uh uh that there's
also in parallel different line of
research uh that uh emerged from uh work
uh in in biology actually initially in
from neuroscience and the study of
neurons to try to model
neural networks the actual neural
networks of the brain with artificial
neural networks that would be uh systems
composed of nodes connected with each
other uh that would process information
from an input layer to output layer so
this is not a system that is neatly
interpretable in terms of a set of
programmatic rules but instead
it's a system that where it's often
referred to as a black box because you
know what goes into it as input and then
you go and know what comes out as output
the output could be for example
classification of an image
um as an image of a dog or an image of a
cat but in the middle are essentially a
bunch of numbers a bunch of Matrix
multiplications performed by these
artificial neural network and these
artificial neural networks so they're uh
are they've been developed
within this this broader category of of
uh research in in computer science
called machine learning where you have a
machine learning from data in this kind
of bottom-up fashion instead of
having this hard-coded programmatic
rules from the top down and uh for a
long time they didn't work very well so
for a very long time
most of the the methods that were
attempted with with machine learning and
neural networks were only effective and
very limited domains and so the symbolic
good old-fashioned AI Paradigm was the
Domino one and then this all changed or
to some extent started to change in the
in the 90s but then certainly in the
2010s with this new era in artificial
intelligence research uh known as deep
learning this is just a variant of
machine learning using uh deep neural
networks instead of just shallow neural
networks that just means that these
artificial neural networks are larger uh
they have not just an input layer an
output layer and a hidden layer in the
middle but a lot of hidden layers that's
why they're deep because they have this
stack of layers that you can think of as
doing some kind of hierarchical
processing of the information that is
fed into the network so the information
again could be an image that is broken
down in terms of pixel values and the
output being classification as cat or
dog but in the middle you have all of
these hidden layers that process
properties features of these of the
input image in order to determine
whether it's a cat or a dog and this
deep learning Paradigm since the early
2010 2010s has really
triumphed in a number of areas of
artificial intelligence including
initially uh computer vision so there
was this big moment where the Deep
learning
approach made great stride with the
imagenet competent which is an image
classification challenge in the early
2010s and since then this has uh uh
percolated into other areas of
artificial intelligence research
including natural language processing
which is the part of AI research that
deals with Building Systems that can
parse generate or and or understand
language so this is the part that is
relevant for modern language models and
so this this development of deep
learnings have led to some innovation in
natural language processing with the
development of new architectures uh one
of the biggest breakthroughs being the
invention of the so-called Transformer
architecture in 2017 and this is
basically the architecture on which
modern language models and chatbots are
based on and this architecture proved to
be remarkably efficient and scalable
and since 2017 with the initial
invention of the Transformer most of the
breakthroughs have been through sheer
engineering prowess rather than uh
finding new newer better architectures
so we've scaled up these neural network
space in the Transformer architecture to
learn from text and we've ended up with
systems like gpt3 that can generate text
fluently
to perform any number of tasks specified
in natural language like English or
French or Spanish such as creating a
poem writing a story about something
answering questions about facts of
worldly facts or
summarizing documents translating and so
on so it's uh it was a really big a
breakthrough in itself because you can
have this model that is just pre-trained
on the large amount of text a
significant subset of the whole internet
all of English Wikipedia hundreds of
thousands of books and millions of web
pages and after this pre-training is
able to to accomplish various scans of
Downstream tasks that it hasn't been
explained basically trained for and then
we get to finally and I'll end there the
modern chatbots and these are chatbots
like chat GPT that have really taken the
World by storm over the past few months
um and these are based on this language
models so again using the Transformer
neural network architecture developed in
2017 and and building on Decades of
research on artificial neural networks
and the little cherry on top that these
models have
is that they take this pre-trained model
trained on uh data script from the
internet and they add a little bit of
fine tuning to make them a little bit
better in certain respects specifically
to make them more helpful
less harmful and more honest or more
prone to uh saying the truth when asked
questions and the way in which this is
done is just by recruiting a number of
human crowd workers and asking the the
model to
generate outputs in response to certain
inputs such as questions about the world
and having the human workers rank the
outputs from the most honest and helpful
and harmless to the least honest and
helpful and harmless and you can then
use what's known as a reinforcement
learning
learning objective which will enable the
model to be fine-tuned to anticipate
which of the outputs are the ones that
humans will judge more helpful less
harmful more honest and after you've
done that you get something like chat
GPT that is generally a less toxic model
than a vanilla large pre-trained
language model is less prone to just
outputting random uh made up facts about
the world that's prone to to
bullshitting in the in the in the
technical philosophical sense that Harry
Frankfort the philosopher proposed which
is uh just you know speaking without any
intrinsic regard for truth or falsity
just to convince to convince the person
you're speaking to the vanilla language
models like gpt3 are very prone to
bullshitting and models that have been
fine-tuned in this in this way are a
little less prone to bullshitting I
guess that's an improvement when we're a
little bit less prone to bullshitting I
mean maybe we could Implement that
beyond the world of large language
models but thank you for that I know
that it was a mouthful but I asked you
to cover a lot of ground there I guess
one of the things that I was thinking of
when you when you gave that explanation
is how close is the linguistic analogy
between a neural network and actual
neurons in the human brain I mean even
just quantitatively like a big language
model how many neurons or neuron
equivalents does it have compared to a
brain yeah so uh it's a lose analogy and
it's one uh we shouldn't take too
seriously so when we talk about
artificial neural networks these are
nothing like actual biological brains
for various reasons uh at the level of
single neurons what uh the equivalent of
a neuron and not even in an official
neural network is is much much simpler
it's just a little node in the network
that those awaited sum of uh the outputs
from the nodes in the previous layer
that I connected to it so it's a very
simple mathematical operation uh whereas
actual uh neurons in the brain are much
more complex in terms of the behavior
they they have the spiking behavior
[Music]
that is more stochastic and also
the way in which uh they are connected
to other neurons is more complicated in
fact it was there was a recent paper
that showed that if you want to try to
approximate the behavior of a single
biological neuron in the in the brain
the human brain or animal brain you
would have to use a fairly complex
artificial neural network just to try to
simulate the behavior of a single neuron
so so there is no mapping there one one
to one and in terms of the size well the
largest models that we have today see
gpt3 has 175 parameters where parameters
refer roughly to the weights in the
connections between the nodes of the
network these artificial neurons
um and uh another model from Google is
even larger it's called Palm it has a
540 billion parameters uh it's rumored
that next this coming Thursday Microsoft
will unveiled gpt4 which might have as
many as one trillion parameters but
um I believe that the human brain has uh
around a 100 trillion synapses uh or uh
you know connections between
between
the the between neurons
um so it's orders have managed more I I
think maybe either you misspoke or I
misheard the number of uh nodes in gpt3
because I heard you say like 170
parameters but there's a word missing
there no I had sorry 170 billion there
he goes
maybe you said that and I didn't hear it
okay but but that's a lot of parameters
okay and am I right that so by
parameters we mean each one of these
nodes takes in some inputs from other
nodes adds or subtracts them and
multiplies them by numbers and these
numbers are the parameters that we're
talking about here and do we start with
a completely blank slate is our is our
neural network initialized to either
random numbers or just numbers one
everywhere before it starts learning
so in some sense we do start with a
blank slate another another sense not uh
and that is because indeed the neural
networks the artificial neural networks
are randomly initialized that just means
the weights in the network start
generally at random there are exceptions
uh but generally the way in which it
works is we just start with random
numbers and then gradually in the
process of training we tune these
weights we tune these numbers uh these
parameters uh such that the model gets
better and better at the learning uh
objective that it has so in the case of
large language models they learn through
a learning objective which is simply a
next token prediction which uh to
simplify a little bit just means next
word prediction so there are sampling
sequences of text from this massive
Corpus of text a subset of the whole
internet and for each sequence they are
trying to predict which word is
statistically most likely to follow from
the words that precede so they can get
it right or wrong so for example
when I'm I'm speaking to you I might say
a sentence like Paris is the capital of
and a model would have to predict that
statistically uh the word most likely to
follow from that would be friends and if
it gets it wrong then there is some
error here that we can use to adjust the
weights inside the network to make it
better next time it has to make a
prediction in that kind of context so we
use this technique called back
propagation which just means we we
propagate the error between the
predicted word and the actual word that
the difference there we use it to
propagate to propagate a signal back
from the output layer to the input layer
of the network to adjust the little
knobs inside the parameters but again
initially it is randomly
initialized so that's a sense in which
you could say it's a blank State there's
another sense in which it's not a blank
slate Because the actual architecture of
the model is not random so back in the
days of the early research and
artificial neural networks the neural
network architectures would be very
simple in what's called I was called the
detender perceptron uh it's a fully
connected
um artificial neural network where all
the nodes at each layer and there was
only uh um there weren't many hidden
layers as there are today uh all the
nodes are are connected to all the nodes
in the uh layer that precedes or follows
so it's fully connected in that sense
whereas current artificial neural
network architectures are much more
sophisticated
and they have quite a lot of of
structure
even though they are initially randomly
initialized that guides the learning
behavior and you can think of the
structure as embedding some
priors some biases what is known in
computer science as inductive biases
that help that help the learning in a
specific domain okay that's very
interesting so there's been a lot as you
already have said uh of progress and
excitement around deep learning in many
different
contexts uh most spectacularly perhaps
originally in image recognition and then
image generation with Dali and so forth
but the most recent excitement has been
about these language models I wanted to
focus on those so you mentioned very
briefly that in some sense all the
language model is doing is predicting
what will come next is is that exactly
right or is there is there a sense in
which it's predicting what sentence will
come next how much depth does it have in
terms of constructing uh coherent text
so uh the lighter is is the case for for
most uh um standard language models and
the ones you uh generally would hear of
like gpt3 chat GPT and so on so these
are really trained
um on to simplify things a little bit on
next word prediction I said to simplify
because uh actually the way in which
they receive linguistic inputs uh is not
neatly broken down in terms of words uh
like the words you and I would use and
see in a sentence but it's actually
receive what's known as tokens where
sometimes a single word can be broken
down into different sub word tokens so
perhaps a word like Freedom would be
broken down into a token for free and a
token for Dom
why is that the case well that's it just
turns out empirically can be quite
helpful to avoid having uh word words
that are out of the vocabulary of the
network for example so say you train
your you're on your network and then you
feed it a new input after training it to
try to generate some text and your input
contains a word that the model has never
seen before that wouldn't work if your
model is trained on whole words you just
wouldn't know how to process that word
whereas if you have these sub word
tokens then say you have you know
freedom is broken then that's free or
dumb if there is another word that
starts with free
your model will already have a token for
that sub word unit so that's just a
technical point which is to say that
technically what these are doing is next
token prediction and tokens don't always
map one-on-one to the words of a
language but just leaving that aside
roughly it's it's equivalent to an extra
prediction and certainly it's not uh for
models like gpt3 and other takes
generation models this is not it's they
are not doing prediction at the level of
a whole sentence okay that said in the
process of learning how to do an expert
prediction they can actually learn a lot
of information about how sentences are
structured uh so what we call the
syntactic structure of language the way
in which different words are related to
each other uh in complex expressions
like sentences yeah I mean when you when
one plays around with chat GPT or the
like which I encourage all listeners to
do if they haven't already probably many
of you have but you may agree or
disagree with what claims it is making
at the level of factualness but it's
very smooth it sounds human right like
they've they've sort of nailed that
problem there's not awkward grammatical
constructions as far as I can tell
exactly exactly it's it's very rare to
uh in fact you really have to try hard
to get these models to generate
ungrammatical sentences uh it's almost
as if they're they're the resisting uh
um the generation of such sentences and
and the reason for that is that they are
trained again on this massive Corpus of
text and this Corpus will include of
course some grammatical mistakes
um but generally they are very good at
as if we're extracting the signal from
the noise and so by and large the
sentences in this Corpus will be
grammatical sentences and it seems that
this is enough for the models to uh
induce in this purely empirical fashion
bottom of fashion just by doing this
next word prediction game on enough data
uh induce uh uh grammatical structure
well this is great because I want to ask
you a question that you'll be tempted to
give a two-hour answer to so let's let's
try to give a brief answer and then we
can sort of amplify it but I want to ask
you know how seriously we should take
the idea that these models are
intelligent are conscious are smart
whatever how however you want to put it
and it's clear that there are two
different intuitions pulling on us one
right one is just like you said all it's
doing is predicting the next word that
doesn't sound very conscious to me it's
just you know a lot of probabilities
getting mixed into a pot on the other
hand you talk to it and boy it certainly
does sound like it's responding to you
in a self-aware kind of way so uh give
me the overview picture of where you
come down or how we should think about
that question and then we can dig into
the details
so the overview would be
um
it would be a mistake to uh um buff
um under estimates or of estimate what
these models do by looking at the wrong
uh level of our of analysis or by
projecting uh human-like traits without
enough evidence on these models uh um as
sometimes we do uh with machines and
some extent with some animals so the
indeed these models only learn through
this next work prediction uh mechanism
now sometimes people will say well that
means that these models they don't have
capacity XYZ because all they do is next
word prediction right I think that's
that's misleading and the reason for
that is that in order to do next work
prediction as uh as well as brilliantly
as they do in any virtually any
linguistic context because again their
training data will Encompass virtual
actually any linguistic context we can
think of from from creative fiction to
Wikipedia to uh you know discussions
between users on a social network in
order to be able to do an extra
prediction in all of these different
contexts well presumably uh our this is
an open empirical question you might
have to acquire quite sophisticated
capacities that
you might not fully grasp by just
focusing on the next prediction learning
objective so here is a is a rough
analogy
you can think of evolution as also
optimizing some kind of function right
so perhaps something like maximizing the
inclusive genetic fitness of organisms
but it would seem weird to say that all
I'm doing when I'm talking to you right
now is maximizing my inclusive genetic
thickness and that I'm not actually for
this wisdom that actually reasoning and
not actually thinking I'm not actually
exercising any intelligent competence
because all I'm doing is is maximizing
this particular function that seems like
a bit of a category mistake and so to
the to to a similar extent what might
think that just saying all these systems
do is Network prediction might not tell
the whole the whole story but it's more
complicated and I will I will keep it to
a short answer it's more complicated
because uh
um you know what we mean when we bring
in the terms intelligence and
Consciousness uh is these are very
loaded complicated multi-phase
multifaceted terms and what we mean can
can differ so first of all I think we
ought to distinguish the question about
Consciousness from the question about
intelligence to the extent that perhaps
these two things can come apart and
we'll talk about that
but also I think one of the challenges
here that we are well faced both
researchers and and journalists talking
about these systems and the public at
large is that when we think of
intelligence and Consciousness but
intelligence in particular we have in
mind the kinds of intelligent
competencies that we humans have and so
it's very uh difficult not to adopt uh
an anthropocentric attitude
to these competencies that uh brings to
mind what what women when we talk about
reasoning uh beliefs desires and so on
in yeah in in the human case and to the
extent that these models might have some
capacities that look functionally like
psychological capacities to a certain
extent or cognitive capacity to a
certain extent these might look quite
different from uh the capacities that
humans have say reasoning uh to the
extent that we might be able to describe
something that is functionally analogous
to some forms of reasoning in these
models this might be quite different
from full-blown
reasoning of the full spectrum of of
competencies risk right versus if we've
reasoning in humans so having this
articulating this nuanced middle view
between uh an inflationary
interpretation of what these models can
do and and the deflationary idea that
they only do an expert prediction and
nothing else is very tricky good but I I
like that explanation in the sense that
there are different ways I wrote a whole
book about the fact that there's one
world the universe and there are
different ways of talking about it right
so the if I can rephrase your answer the
question about whether or not these
models are intelligent uh I mean maybe
they're not intelligent in some
particular sense and we shouldn't over
inflate them but at least in principle
it would be possible that they really
are intelligent or even more and yet
still just be predicting the next word
with some frequency like those are not
incompatible things it's not either or
exactly yeah but to drive home why
people are so impressed by them like one
is the chatbot aspect right people can
talk to them but the other is that you
can ask them to do things that it seems
like they would require reasoning right
like famously people are asking these
large language models to prove
mathematical theorems or to write
Snippets of code to do a task I don't
know do you know Bell's theorem in
quantum mechanics have you ever heard of
that yeah vaguely yeah yeah I I I asked
chat GPT to write to explain Bell's
theorem uh in the form of a haiku and
here's what it came up with Quantum
pairs apart measurements yield values
true non-locality which is really good I
gotta say like better than Haiku than
most philosophers of physics would come
up with trying to explain that so it it
does if you you sort of hinted at this
idea of
anthropomorphizing and the intentional
stance if we want to talk about that
that Daniel Dennett talks about like the
human being seeing this kind of behavior
can't help but attribute reason to it
right yes it's very hard to to resist
ascribing psychological properties to
these models when we interact with them
um it's very hard because this is
probably the first time in our
evolutionary history uh where where we
we're confronted with systems that can
they can speak fluently or or in that
case generate text fluently and yet uh
you know are not uh other human beings
with all the capacities we can ascribe
to them and therefore the really
challenges or intuitions about uh how to
how to think about these these models
and what they can do
um so the immediate the the intuition we
have is that we must be in the presence
of something very intelligent and
perhaps there is a more or principled
weaker claim that we can make on the
basis of more careful careful and
critical investigation on these models
which is that
depending on how you slice up the notion
of intelligence how you think about it
what perhaps you could meaningfully
ascribe some limited uh cognitive
capacities to these models that share
some functional similarity to some
cognitive capacities humans have like
reasoning but this would not cover the
full spectrum of uh what we mean by
reasoning in other cognitive capacities
in humans but I think we also Ode to
ascribe these capacities and investigate
them on a case-by-case basis I said
earlier we were to distinguish between
the Consciousness question and the
intelligence question and then we also
know ought to to you know
divide the questions about psychological
capacities into into different
categories one is reasoning another one
would be whether we could ascribe
beliefs to these models another one
would be whether we can describe
something like like desire there is a
question of whether they can understand
language and so on and so forth and I
think uh by having a divide and concur
strategy we can make more progress on
these discussions I I'm very sympathetic
to that in part because I did a podcast
interview with Stuart Bartlett uh who
works on the origin of life and his
whole thing is what do you mean by life
there's many different aspects of life
and we could imagine systems that are
some of them but not others and you're
saying the same thing for intelligence
or Consciousness or reasoning with which
I could not agree with more but um good
I think that with that on the ground we
can actually dig in a little bit more
to the philosophy both in the common
sense sense of the word and the
technical sense of the word of what's
going on here you mentioned
symbolic versus connectionist approaches
and how the large language models which
are based on deep learning are therefore
connectionist in Outlook so is there a
simple reason why the connectionist
approaches have been so much more
successful in recent years is I mean are
human beings bad I I think of it as the
symbolic approach sort of tries to First
teach the computer some common sense and
then the computer goes on from there
whereas the connections approach teaches
the computer almost nothing and the
computer learns everything it sounds
like it's better to leave the computer
alone to do its own learning than to try
to teach it common sense ahead of time
yes indeed that's that's perhaps one of
the uh potentially surprising findings
of the of the past decade at least for
those who have been skeptical of the
connectionist approach is that it seems
that in virtually every domain of
artificial intelligence research it is
more effective to let connectionist
models the artificial neural networks
learn from data I learned empirically
from the bottom up advantages to try to
distill human knowledge into a neatly
interpretable set of symbolic rules and
axioms and the way in which we used to
do things with uh traditional symbolic
models so that in fact has come to be
known uh as the bitter lesson of
artificial intelligence research this is
a phrase that the Google researcher Rich
Sutton kind a few years ago and the beta
lesson is that essentially over and over
again over the recent history of of AI
research that will observed is that
we've tried to make better models by
infusing them hard coding into them some
more in its human knowledge about the
world or about whatever domain they're
supposed to process us that could be for
example if you're trying to build a
model that can classify pictures into uh
with labels corresponding to different
animals present in the pictures perhaps
you could be tempted to use them the
knowledge that we have about animals and
what they look like by a hand coding
a feature detector that is specifically
designed to try to detect uh edges that
that look like pose and edges that look
like ear pointy ears and and so on and
so forth
it turns out it's it's always more
effective to just let the models the
models learn that by themselves by
simply training them on millions of
images and giving them some feedback
about whether they are right or wrong so
you get the model to make a prediction
is that a cat is that a dog is that a
tiger and the model will make an out and
provide an output which is label it's a
predicted label for the class of the
image and again you can compare
addiction with the grand truth what is
actually
the corresponding label for that image
and then you can propagate the error
backwards into the model and adjust the
weights and let the model adjust its
internal representations in a way that
makes it more efficient at doing this
kind of prediction task so that's the
beta lesson it seems that
over and over again it's very there is a
sense which is it's very intellectually
unsatisfying for us uh to to think that
we have really not much to contribute in
terms of init knowledge
to these models uh and and you know the
same applies to the linguistic domain
with this large language networks that
don't have any priors any any intrinsic
in its knowledge about grammar they
learn from raw text by this next word
prediction objective but we don't
actually give them anything uh by way of
an init grammar of the kind that Nom
Chomsky in linguistics postulated uh uh
um as the Universal init knowledge that
every human has to to learn language
so it's a it's an interesting uh point
for for two reasons it's an interesting
point for engineering if your goal is
simply to build models that are more
more efficient at doing something say
generating haikus about quantum physics
or classifying images as matches of dogs
and cats uh that's that's you know
that's just an engineering goal and you
will throw every possible solution at
your problem and use whatever solution
is most efficient it turns out the most
efficient solution is the one that
leverages the learning power of
artificial neural networks
so most of the big companies building
these large net models like open AI with
chat GPT they have million engineering
goals I say merely not because these are
simple goals are extremely complex but
they don't have really their goal is not
really scientific understanding now if
your goal is more of a scientific goal
and you are trying to use these models
perhaps to constrain uh or develop
hypotheses about how say human or animal
cognition Works how things work actually
for us and that was to a large extent
the initial goal of connectionism that
that was very much tipped in this
scientific project
then the beta lesson is also rather
interesting and might uh nudge you
towards a more empiric empiricist
stance towards the way in which humans
and animals learn if it turns out that
you might not need as much init
knowledge as we might have thought to
learn to perform various tasks you know
it's possible that humans do things in a
different way it's possible that they do
it with more in-it knowledge so for
example it's possible that Shamsky is
correct that we have a universal grammar
that is encoded in DNA and that's how we
can learn languages but perhaps you know
the recent evolution of language models
puts a little bit of pressure on that
kind of claim because it suggests that
there are things that we didn't think
were learnable without init priors but
in its biases that perhaps are learnable
the question is how much you can
transfer from what you find about these
artificial neural networks given how
different they are and how differently
they learn from biological agents how
much you can infer from that to the
human case or the animal case I can
imagine the following scenario tell me
what you think that the way that human
beings actually learn and use language
which is highly uh compartmentalized
compositional maybe I can say but then
you should explain what that means is
useful is efficient in some ways you
know like given finite processing power
and and other demands on our energy
budget maybe it's the right way way to
go but at the same time we are very bad
at realizing how we think about things I
mean I think it's well known that there
are all sorts of athletes and musicians
and artists who are really good at their
task and terrible at teaching other
people how to be good at their task
terrible at even articulating what it is
that they are doing so maybe the lesson
is just not that it's better to have a
featureless neural network that trains
itself randomly but just that don't let
human beings be the ones to decide how
the neural network should organize
itself because we're bad at that
yes that that's that's right I think
um
um we if anything I think the progress
of connectionism uh gives us a little
bit of a lesson in humility uh in terms
of how we approach the modeling of human
cognition uh that said it also it also
is worth saying that you know sometimes
the uh the terms of the debate are
caricatured and it's something like
either your connectionist and you think
the mind is a tabula Raza when you're
when you're born uh and you'll learn
everything uh uh empirically with no
bias in it bias at all uh or uh uh
you're not you're not uh you know you're
you're a nativist and you think there is
uh a lot of of in its uh very specific
domain specific unit biases that are
that are encoded uh um in the mind and
and uh and that you don't learn
um but the fact is that modern
artificial neural networks as I already
mentioned they have they have bias
so they have uh this image structure is
just generally uh of a different kind
than or of a more General kind than some
of the biases that are often
hypothesized to be
um necessary for learning uh uh and for
cognition in humans so an example would
be a language again if you're a chumskin
linguist you think um there is this
Universal grammar which is a kind of
domain language specific domain specific
init knowledge
that can perform certain uh uh uh you
know encodes knowledge to perform
certain operations that like unbounded
merge we don't have to get into the the
specifics of of this kind of of grammar
but
um the difference with language models
is that they have different inductive
biases that are given by the Transformer
architecture these are more General but
they are still biases that enable them
to learn uh induce various properties of
language efficiently
um and so here one question is uh is
there a shop divide uh between uh these
two approaches or not
can there be some kind of Continuum
where you can have more or less
stronger or weaker inductive biases
um and so that's the first point so so
maybe there is this Continuum in terms
of the strength of the these biases
there might be a Continuum in terms of
their domain specificity as well uh you
know is is the universal grammar of
tropical Linguistics really domain
specific is it not perhaps you know uh
something especially if you think uh as
Chomsky does that uh it's uh
um uh very importantly related to our
ability to think as well
um you know is is it perhaps uh a little
bit more dumb in general than uh
um is usually thought and uh and another
point would be that
um you know how to think of in its
biases in the biological world where
these these biases have been tuned by uh
The evolutionary history of organisms
and you can look at this evolutionary
history uh as a learning process in some
sense as well uh and so there is a
question about what is the right level
of comparison between in artificial
neural networks that are randomly
initialized and then gradually
with their init biases tune their
weights and the the evolution
evolutionary history of the biases that
humans and animals might have if you
think of evolution as a learning process
uh albeit not not albeit not at the
scale of individuals but at the scale of
uh whole species
then you might think that even what we
think of as init knowledge uh in the
case of human and animals is is also
learned from this evolutionary history
and of course things are more much more
complicated in the biological case
because for example the wiring of the
brain is not something that's obviously
totally random although it's it's
somewhat stochastic but there is a big
genetic influence there is a very
interesting book by Kevin Mitchell about
this called init that I really recommend
and uh and of our various interactions
you know during development uh early the
early development of humans and animals
uh between the the genetic programming
uh that determines uh some structural
aspects of of the wiring of the brain as
it develops and uh also the environment
in which the organism develops uh so to
that extent even the architecture of the
brain in terms of the actual wiring of
it and the shape of the connection is
something that
involves a little bit of stochasticity a
little bit of Randomness in development
but is is driven by uh by genetic
programming uh whereas the architecture
of neural networks currently is
something that is still hand coded by
humans even though the weights
themselves initialization initialization
is not hand coded but there are there is
Research into evolutionary algorithms
for neural networks that we try to find
better architectures also through this
kind of evolutionary search that that's
very interesting I had not heard about
that has that gotten very far yet so far
uh I mean there is some some proof of
concept research but it hasn't really
led to breakthroughs as far as I know uh
architectural breakthroughs so so far uh
uh to the the beta lesson has a lesson
encompassed uh the design of
architectures but uh you could imagine
that that might be the case at some
point I would like to ask how this
relates to the word and the idea
compositionality because you know we
mentioned a couple times without really
digging into it and it has I'm not an
expert here I know that it roughly has
to do with you know the relationship
between parts and holes right how things
get divided up and then added back
together and I was struck that literally
this morning on the day that we're
recording this interview uh there's a
Twitter discussion from my Hopkins
colleague Chaz Firestone who is a
psychologist about recent results that
claim the compositionality applies to
visual cognition as well to linguistic
cognition so what is this idea that is
seemingly so important at least for
human beings yes so compositionality uh
is an idea that uh was first and
foremost uh well-defined in a linguistic
domain uh has a property of of a
language so uh the canonical formulation
comes from uh the linguist Barbara party
um who Define compositionality in the
language as uh uh the principle uh
According to which the meaning of a
complex expression say a whole sentence
is determined by the meaning of the
constituent elements of that expression
say single words together which together
with the way in which these words are
composed in the complex expression
meaning the syntax of the expression the
structure of the expression or the
sentence
um
is an ordered list of words not just a
bucket of words said that the ordering
doesn't matter exactly it's an it's an
it's it's not just a bag of words as we
say in in natural language processing
sometimes right it's it's it has a
specific order and this order uh obeys
um uh you know is is maps onto a
specific kind of hierarchical structure
that you can uh actually analyze in
terms of a tree uh what linguists called
parse trees
um
um so so that's quite important the
meaning uh of the sentence uh man bites
dog is different from this meaning of
the sentence dog bites man uh and uh and
uh if you just think of these as as a
bag of words so as as the the set of the
words dog man and bytes
um you you won't be able to to uh grasp
the difference so language natural
language like uh English uh French
Spanish and so on uh seems to uh to some
degree uh conform to this principle of
compositionality I said to some degree
because there are there are a lot of
aspects of this General Principle as
I've stated it that are a bit
underspecified uh in particular whether
the meaning of the complex expression is
strictly determined by the meaning of
the constituent words together with the
structure
whether that's the only meaning you can
ascribe to the complex expression and so
on so
um I would say a slightly weaker but
more accurate formulation of the
principle for natural language would be
that the meaning of a complex expression
is at least partly determined by uh
um these two things the meaning of the
words and the meaning of which uh they
are combined and that's at least one of
the meanings that you can ascribe to a
complex expression the reason I say that
is because in language we have idioms
for example and idioms are typically not
understood compositionally because uh
they have this these are complex
Expressions that have received me
meaning that is not necessarily built up
from the meaning of the constituent
Parts
they behave functionally almost as you
know as a single word it's just uh they
have this received meaning
um you also have some values extra
linguistic influences on meaning that
come from the context in which uh
certain occurrences are made and so on
and and these also are influences on how
you parse the meaning of complications
but we can leave that aside and roughly
think of natural language as
compositional okay so that's for
language
um but then uh it seems that perhaps you
you can uh Loosely apply a similar
principle to say uh the meaning of a of
a picture for example uh so the analogy
is imperfect and uh there are various
details that you could discuss there but
perhaps you can think well the way in
which you understand uh the
representation of a visual scene uh can
also be broken down in terms of
understanding uh the different objects
in the scene together with the way in
which they come together in the scene uh
so to that extent perhaps it makes sense
to talk about uh if not syntax at least
structure in an image
that applies to different elements that
are put together uh again thinking of
the the dog and man example you could
think of a picture that represents a man
running and a dog running if you see the
the man running in front of the da you
could you could infer that uh the the
dog is chasing the man and vice
Versailles the dog is running in front
of a man you could infer that the the uh
the man is chasing the dog yes uh so so
so that's uh that's how compositionality
might uh also apply to to the visual
domain so now we've talked the right
compositionality as a property of
certain
systems of representation whether it's
it's linguistic or visual uh but people
talk about compositionality as applying
not just to perhaps language or images
but also uh applying to uh the cognitive
systems that process uh language or and
images so there we move to another of
compositionality that applies to the way
in which the the human mind say is
processing linguistic or visual
information the kinds of representation
it has in the way to which it's building
them up uh into more complex
representations and the idea is
symbolize the idea that uh when I in
order to be able to understand the
meaning of the sentence uh man bites
dark I need to understand the meaning of
the constituent of words and I need to
put these meanings together into the
meaning of the complex expression so
that's not just not just the property of
the language itself it's a property of
the way in which I process the language
in my in my brain in my mind uh and if
you think that's a property of language
processing uh or perhaps visual
processing as well as suggested by this
recent research that you alluded to from
chat Firestone and colleagues then you
might also think that's property of
thinking as well so when I think the
thoughts mind bites dark
my ability to think that thought might
be
premised upon my ability to think uh to
to to think about men think about dogs
think about the biting relation and
compose these things together into this
compositional complex thoughts
um so that's the idea of
compositionality and traditionally uh
the charge uh from uh opponents of
connectionist models has been that
connection is models are not adequate
models of cognition of cognition partly
because they are unable to account for
the compositionality of thoughts
um and so that has been the
long-standing debate uh and uh the
reason for that is that it is very
straightforward to
account for compositionality in a more
classical symbolic system because you
have discrete symbolic representations
like a symbol for dog a symbol for man
and a symbol for bikes and you could put
this together with a well-defined
syntactic rules that just determine how
this could be combined into the syntax
of the complex expression or the complex
representation mind byte stock and in
that process you would have literally
the expression mind bite and dog or the
biting relation being co-token being
coincidence shaded into the complex
expression so it has this discrete
constituent structure where the Inc the
the discrete symbolic elements are
brought together into the complex
representation and in in connection is
models that's not typically the case the
if you have a representation for a man
one for dog and one for the biting
relation these will typically be a
subsymbolic representations that are
distributed into the activations of the
network
um and uh such that the representation
for the complex expression man bites dog
will not uh will not neatly
be decomposable in terms of
representations of the individual
elements it will just be yet another
distributed representations that has
been the traditional attack on
connections models when it's a
compositionality is it conceivable that
the large language models essentially
discover composite additionality in some
sense I'm thinking of when I had Judea
Pearl on the podcast uh he claimed that
babies spend their time constructing
causal maps of the world they poke
things they see what the reaction is and
that you know they map a model of the
world in their head and I don't know can
we look inside a large language model or
a deep learning model and identify oh
when it's thinking about running or
biting this part lights up or is that
just beyond our capabilities
no I think it's indeed a very promising
Avenue of research is going Beyond
looking at the behavior of these models
and actually trying to make some
stronger claims about the the internal
mechanisms that explain their behavior
so that's a whole area of research that
has come to be known as mechanistic
interpretability in computer science and
computational Linguistics and uh it's a
an area of research that interestingly
borrows a lot of tools from
cognitive science and Neuroscience in
particular because these models these
black boxes uh well although they're
very very different from the human brain
as we've discussed there is only a loose
analogy there in so far as there are
black boxes where we know what comes in
we know that comes out but it's
difficult to interpret what's going on
in the middle we can take a leap from
the book of uh Decades of research in
neuroscience and psychology to try to
understand the mechanisms of the black
boxes that are the human that is the
human mind or the human brain in order
to try to adapt these tools and study
what's going on inside these artificial
neural networks so there are various
things you can do
one of the easier things you could do is
just try to decode what information
uh is available in the internal
representations of the model uh of the
international internal encodings of the
model that are embedded in the weights
of the model and to do that you can you
can train a classifier
that will see whether
certain kinds of information are
decodable from the weights of the model
so for example you can see whether a
language model
encodes information that corresponds to
syntactic postures you can do that and
you can actually empirically show that
indeed you can reconstitute the
syntactics pastries of so so this kind
of classical linguistic syntactic
structure of a sentence from uh the
internal encodings of a of of uh a
language model now just because you can
do that that's only correlation right so
if you can't necessarily infer from that
that your model is actually using making
use of that information in order to
generate certain outputs so there you
have to go further than that and develop
more interventionist techniques where
you can manipulate the internal
representations of the networks
and see whether this has a downstream
effect on the outputs of the of the
model and that can give you uh more
causal inferences so again this is
roughly similar to what you could do in
Neuroscience you can try to decode
information from a from a brain from
from uh patterns of neural activation or
you could try intervention such as use
using a magnetic transcranial
stimulation to disrupt
a particular area in the brain and see
what other Downstream so we can do that
and uh perhaps the more the most refined
uh kind of approach in the realm of
mechanistic interpretability is to look
at toy models that are very very small
in terms of the number of parameters
they have and because they're small
they're easier to to grok as it were and
try to reverse engineer the circuits
that these models are implementing after
being trained so again if you think of
these models as being trained on next
token prediction
just knowing that they perform next
token prediction and that they have a
certain architecture is not enough to
make principled claims about the kinds
of computations that they're able to
perform after training because they
learn from data and they they adjust
their internal weights and and in that
process they learn to perform certain
computations you could say they induce a
repertoire of computations and it's an
open empirical question that you cannot
settle a priori to determine what these
computations are right and so by reverse
engineering these torrent models you can
get at some of the basic building blocks
of what they're actually doing and that
work is is is really uh you know a
painstaking analysis By Hand by looking
at specific layers of the network and
looking at specific neurons Within These
layers and trying to see what kind of uh
information they are attending to
preferentially what they are sensitive
to and and how different layers between
in the network uh interact with each
other as well but there is emerging
evidence from this line of work that
shows that uh indeed uh there might be a
form of a compositional representation
in these models that emerges
that is not classical it is it does not
involve this this discrete constituent
structure where you can take the
representation for uh dog mine and
biting the writing relation and and
literally just concatenate these into a
complex representation that
co-instantiates this different simple
representations it's not like that you
know in a large language model uh the
simple words are represented in vectors
in a large in a high dimensional Vector
space
um and there is information that is
encoded about the way in which the words
relate to each other
um and that information is encoded by uh
shifting uh adjusting the the vectors uh
for the words in that Vector space So at
the input layer the model is only
turning each each word from the from the
input say at the sentence uh man bites
dog into three vectors one vector for uh
man one vector for bytes for dog and
these are don't include any information
about how these words connect to each
other there is no compositional
representation there but as these
vectors get processed processed in the
hierarchy of the network you have
different sub modules in the network
that I call attention module we don't
have to get into the details but these
modules as it turns out as we found from
this mechanistic interpretability work
um can actually read and write
information into to subspaces of the
high dimensional space in ways that look
very looks very analogous to a Content
addressable memory in a classical
architecture so you can
read and write information about
specific kinds of dependencies or
relationship between the words that
could be for example subject verb
agreement so syntax in syntactic
relationship or that can be about boss
semantic kinds of relationship about how
the meaning of words relate to each
other in the sentence
and
that doesn't literally concatenate
representations together with this
classical discrete
constituent structure but it's doing a
more sophisticated form of of
composition that can still keep certain
uh
attributes of the different words
neatly separated by reading and writing
information to distinct subspaces so
again if you think of the idea that the
model tracks the fact that one of the
words is the verb and that the verb
relates to the subject in substance uh
you might want that kind of information
to be tracked separately from the
information that the uh the verb uh has
a certain uh you know semantic meaning
in that case you know referring to the
baiting biting relation so you might
want to uh to to track different
different properties different features
of the different elements of the
sentence uh separately and it seems that
these models are able to to do that okay
so I don't want to over interpret what
you say Let me let me give a shot as
seeing whether I understood uh what is
going on here so it sounds like
um the hypothesis that in the course of
training your large language model some
kind of structure some kind of uh
modularity of different pieces playing
different roles does appear in the way
that the nerve the nodes organize
themselves I mean maybe this is way over
interpreting but remember that uh famous
funny study on in Neuroscience that said
that different people would each have a
Jennifer Aniston neuron like there was
one neuron that would always light up
when you mentioned Jennifer Aniston or
showed a picture or whatever so is there
a Jennifer Aniston Vector in every large
language model who knows what she is
yeah so actually that's uh that's a
really interesting question because
there there was there has been some work
on single neurons in
um in such models not just in language
models but also in
multimodal models how many models that
are trained not just on text but also on
say images so an example would be Dali 2
that probably many of the listeners
would be familiar with this is an image
generation algorithm that can receive a
text prompt as inputs a description of a
desired image and can generate
the relevant image from there and that
kind of model has a vector space that
jointly encodes information about text
linguistic information and information
about images visual visual information
um and so there was a study uh about the
neurons found in uh it was actually a I
I remember Berkeley Dali so the ancestor
of Dali 2 the first first version that
found that looked at single neurons and
found that it had these subject-specific
domain-specific neurons
but interestingly so so these are
neurons that would get preferentially
activated in respond to certain kinds of
stimuli but interestingly these were uh
uh mixing you know responsive to
Concepts across modalities at different
levels of abstraction so one example
would be they would they found a spider
neuron that would be
preferentially active related by uh
um images of spiders or the word spider
or images of Spiderman
which you know look very different for
images of actual spider but relate
conceptually to Spiderman to spiders
um so uh so you find indeed that kind of
uh that kind of representation in in
neural networks uh at the level of
single neurons okay that's very
interesting to hear and it lets us come
back to the question now that we have a
lot of domain knowledge on the table
here
um let's ask the big philosophical
questions about whether or not a large
language model has Intelligence or
understands in some sense and probably
the answer is well it depends on the
sense so good you're a philosopher you
can help us uh uh explain that but I
will preface uh your answer by giving
chat gpt's answer I asked it whether it
really understood things and chat GPT
says as an AI language model I don't
have the capacity to know in the way
that humans do so there you go why is
there even controversy about this
yeah you just have to ask them yeah
straight from the horse's mouth
um yes it is it is a it is a thorny
question it is a question that is that
it's very uh loaded with um both
polysemy and controversy because we use
this these terms like understanding in
different ways uh and also people are
prone to jump to conclusion when these
terms get uh thrown around so the first
thing I would again reemphasize is that
uh I think we ought to have a divide and
conquer attitude to these problems uh
and approach them in this piecemeal
manner where instead of asking uh are
language models intelligent uh we can
ask do they have specific competences
that we associate with intelligent
behaviors in humans and non-human
animals and for each of these
competencies we might further break
these Downs into uh into sub
competencies until we can get something
that's a little bit more empirically
tractable yeah that is less ambiguous
that is less susceptible to give rise to
merely verbal dispute
and that we can relate to actual
functions that can be associated with
mechanisms in the model so so that's how
I approach this kind of lineup inquiry
so among the things we're specific
intelligence indeed would be for humans
something like the ability to understand
language because we know that non-human
animals there is really no non-human
animals that has displayed the capacity
to understand language in the way humans
have we've tried to teach language to
Paris to chimpanzees and to various
animals and it never never really quite
quite works we can have some very
limited success in in in very narrow
cases but it seems that we humans are
the only naturally occurring organisms
capable of uh understanding length um so
um the problem is that when we talk
about understanding some people like to
think of this as uh encompassing
something like a conscious awareness of
the meaning of language so the
philosopher John Searle for example uh
had that kind of intuition
um and that models the water a little
bit because uh again it brings back
through through the window uh this other
notion of Consciousness where I think we
can in principle uh investigate uh a
more functional notion of language
understanding without bringing in
necessarily uh questions about sentence
and Consciousness sure so the way in
which I would reform in that thing is is
more in terms of semantic competence uh
which relates to the capacity to parse
the meaning of linguistic Expressions uh
which again is a slightly more
theoretically neutral or less loaded way
to think of that notion of understanding
that might not immediately bring in
intuitions about about conscious
awareness
um and uh so so the question would be
how you know can we describe any any
degree in any form of semantic
competence to language models
um and I would say that we can and
that's now I'm I'm venturing into okay
controversial territory uh some people
would say no you can absolutely not
ascribe any of that because language
models only deal with the surface form
of text there are only again this this
idea we come back to the only trend for
an expert prediction they are only
predicting which token which word should
follows from a sequence of tokens or
words
um so all they grapple with is
the syntactic form of text just you know
the series of symbols uh that follow
each other in a sequence of tokens uh
there never has have access to uh the
grounding of these symbols in in the
world
um and so this is why researchers like
the linguist Emily Bender have referred
to these language models as stochastic
power
which is a little bit misleading because
actual power is actually very
intelligent and are able to interact
with the real world and so on but the
idea is rather that these models are
just parroting uh language without any
underlying understanding uh without any
semantic competence the only uh latch
onto shallow heuristics about the
surface statistics of language uh and
that that's all they do now I did agree
with that and I disagree because first
of all I think semantic competence is
not a monolithical notion uh and uh can
be broken down into different things
that different capacities we have that
relate to run to our understanding of
the meaning of words let's just stick to
words first because when we introduce
wholesome it's even more complicated but
let's stick to lexical semantic
competence that's and passing word
meaning
um so here I I'm indebted to among other
people uh the work of of uh Diego
Marconi
um who distinguishes between
referential and inferential competence
so referential competence is the ability
that relates to this idea of a relating
word meaning to their worldly reference
to what whatever uh that are referencing
out there uh in the world and this is uh
exhibited by things like recognitional
capacities so if I ask you to point to a
dog uh you will be able to do that or if
you ask you to name uh the anim you know
name name that thing and not point to a
dog you'll be able to do that or uh it's
also you know uh displayed in our
ability to parse instructions and
translate them into actions in the world
such as uh you know go fetch uh the fork
in the drawer in the kitchen you will be
able to do that in the world right so
we're able to relate uh lexical
Expressions where their referential uh
with a reference in the world
um but that's not the the that's not the
only aspect of meaning uh that's the
aspect of meaning that the people
talking about the stochastic para
technology are focusing on but um
ability to understand warming also a
hinges on relationships within Works
themselves intra-linguistic relationship
and these are the kinds of relationships
that uh are uh at display in definitions
such as the ones you find in a
dictionary as well as Vice other
relationships of
um of synonymy and and homonymy that
would also underlie our capacity to
perform certain inferences uh in
language
um and so to illustrate that point uh
you can consider uh someone who's
perhaps you know uh let's say a
eucalyptus expert
who knows you know who but but who who
knows all you know all there is to know
scientifically about eucalyptus trees uh
from uh you know reading books
um uh back you know in in the city in
New York say going to University and so
on but has never actually been in the in
the eucalyptus Forest right versus
someone who actually has grown up uh
surrounded by eucalyptus trees and might
know I might not know very little about
the biology of eucalyptus trees or
various information about that but then
but but has gone around them so the the
the eucalyptus specialist uh might have
a very high degree of inferential
competence when it comes to the use of
the word eucalyptus being able to use it
in definitions and uh to know exactly
how different are the words including
biological terms would relate to the
word eucalyptus and so on uh but you
know perhaps if you put that specialist
in a forest that had eucalyptus trees
and a very similar tree I mean my
knowledge of this Hardware yeah I
couldn't a knowledge of eucalyptus is is
really really low uh but uh you know
perhaps there's a tree that looks very
much like eucalyptus trees but that
experts might not a be able to actually
recognize which of the eucalypt
histories which aren't even though it
has all this knowledge so it's actually
referential competence when it comes to
the use of that word uh might not be
that great whereas the person who has
grown up around eucalyptus trees might
be excellent at pointing to eucalyptus
trees even if it has very uh very little
inferential competence when it comes to
using that that term in in definitions
for example uh uh or knowing this more
finding relations between the word
eucalyptus and various other other words
so that's just a very you know toy
example
um but um clearly there are aspects of
meaning
that are very important in the way we
understand and use words that are not
just exhausted by this referential
relation to the world and this second
aspect is inferential aspect of meaning
is something that language models are
well placed to induce just because they
are trained on
this big large copper of text to learn
statistical relationships right between
words and you might think that in so far
as there are these complex
intra-linguistic relationship between
words then a modal that learns uh to uh
model the patterns of co-occurrence
between words at a very very
sophisticated fine grain level might
learn uh uh you know to represent this
inter-linguistic relationship you know
Jacques famously said there is nothing
outside the text maybe he was uh
standing up for the rights of large
language models before they and their
ability to understand things before they
ever came along but I mean it makes
sense to me look these corpuses of text
corpai I'm not sure of text that the
models are trained on
are constructed mostly by people who
have experience with the world it would
be weird if the large language model
could not correctly infer some things
about the world so we're going to count
that on the side of the Ledger for a
kind of understanding that these AI
systems do have right
exactly yes
um and in fact I think you know you you
could even say something about some very
limited and weak form of referential
competence in these models but maybe
they would take us too far afloat but in
these I think uh insofar as the the
statistics of language
um reflects to some extent uh in some at
least in some domains the structure of
the world uh you you you can absolutely
think that uh you can latch onto
something there uh about the structure
of the world just by learning from
statistics of language one example would
be there this this wonderful uh paper by
Ellie Pavlik uh from uh Brown University
that showed that
um you can
um
use color terms like color words like
orange red blue and so on
um
and you can you can look at how language
models are able to uh to represent this
this uh color terms uh and I'm
simplifying a little bit from the study
to not get into too many details but uh
you can map the the representational
geometry of uh the way in which the
model represent these uh terms uh in a
vector space to add the geometry of the
color space uh that is the actual uh you
know relationship say the RGB color
space which is a way to just represent
relationships between colors so there is
something about the structure of the
encodings for word terms in these models
uh that
encodes information or is somehow
isomorphic to uh uh the the structure of
uh colors out there in the world if you
think the RGB color space is going to
represent that uh again I'm making some
simplifying assumption to discuss kind
of research but it's still very it's
still a very uh intriguing finding
can a large language model have an
imagination
uh yeah that's a really that's a really
interesting question uh I suppose it
depends what you mean by imagination
that's again I'm going to be this
annoying philosopher who perfectly
brings things back to the two
definitions and distinctions
um you know some people are more uh I
think I think people are generally more
prone to using that that term for these
uh image generation uh models because
they're you know they are uh they are
able to to generate these uh you know
striking images uh that
um compared to the text prompt they
receive seem to add in a lot of detail
just because uh the resolution of
language as it were is not quite the
same as the resolution of images I mean
that's just a very simplific simplistic
way to to to explain the phenomenon but
but uh the way in which describes things
in uh language leaves a lot of uh gaps
for an image narration models to feel
when it's generating an image and so
when people ask for I don't know a
picture of a cat on the mat and get as a
as an output picture that has all of
these wonderful Rich details and colors
and a specific kind of map specific kind
of cats maybe it's a tabby cat maybe
it's a tuxedo cat and so on you you
might be uh tempted to think well that's
that's really remarkably imaginative uh
there is a the model has filled in the
gaps there in remarkable ways uh but you
know you could also think about the
imagination in the in the linguistic
domain as well uh you gave this
wonderful example of a haiku about
Belle's theorem uh that might feel
pretty creative pretty imaginative in
some in some way
um I think it depends uh what you mean
by imagination whether you bring in this
idea that uh there is some kind of
explicit underlying intention to uh
create visualize uh something just you
know uh write a poem or or create an
artwork or something like that
um I think that might be leaning a
little bit too far in the in the
direction of anthropomorphism
um however in in a loser sense you might
say well
um here is a way to a personalize this
notion of imagination one question is
whether these models are merely as the
authors of the stochastic Parts paper
puts it Hub has at least teaching
together bits and pieces from the
training data yeah so is the performance
merely explainable by this kind of Brute
Force memorization uh or is it doing
something a little something more which
is genuine novelty uh generalizing from
the training data to new domains and
creating outputs that
are not remotely similar to anything in
the training data and I think you know
it's it's it's it's uh you can actually
study this empirically again I always
try to bring it back to problems that
are on retractable
perhaps unusually for a philosopher but
I think you can make Headway on these
issues by looking at the empirical
evidence from research where you can
actually
assess the amount of memorization that
has occurred in training of a model and
you can provably show that uh well there
is memorization
which is a feature and not a bug because
you want your language model to memorize
certain things including if you ask your
model to to recite a certain famous poem
by John Keats
you uh you know it's it's quite nice
that your model is able to do that but
you also want your model to not just do
memorization and to generalize and it's
provably accurate to say that indeed
there is some generalization uh to uh
at least some level of generalization to
some
domains that are out of the the out of
distribution for the model so that might
look in the for the image iteration
models uh like the ability to generate
images that don't look like anything the
images they've been trained on and that
is you might call that in a perhaps a
loser or more deflationary sensor form
of imagination no I love that answer
actually
um it is an important distinction
between interpolation and extrapolation
right uh you what are you saying if I
understand correctly is that the large
language models seem to be doing more
than just plagiarizing and pastiching
and remixing they seem to be
generalizing is the word you use which I
suppose is the right word but you know
somehow finding a theme or an idea or a
style and doing something arguably new
in that style and if we're not going to
call that creativity or imagination then
what should we call it yes exactly I
mean it's it's uh there was an
interesting discussion recently
um I don't know if you've seen this this
op-ed published by Ted Chang in the New
York Times this is about chat GPT and
um it it uh it it's wonderfully written
as anything teaching writes
um uh I think it's it's in many ways a
wonderful essay but it builds this
metaphor that I think is a little bit
misleading which Compares chat gbt to
lossy compression of images uh say the
jpeg compression format is a way we have
to compress images
um and you know some of these image
compression formats uh they uh are able
to reconstitute a lossy approximation of
uh uh the the original image based on
the compressed representation uh it's
Lassie because it doesn't include all of
the same details that's why you see
artifacts in artifacts in jpeg images
sometimes but it's able to do that by
with a certain uh compression and
decompression algorithm and uh one way
one one strategy that can be used is
again this idea of interpolation in
pixel space so you might you might uh
for example a very simplistic form of
compression maybe just uh saving
information about uh two pixels but not
the pixel in between so that allows you
to compress the image and save it in a
in within in a smaller file and then a
deep compression during decompression
you would interpolate the middle pixel
uh by uh you know you can have more or
less sophisticated ways of doing that
but a very simplistic basic way which is
just to take the the average value
perhaps of the two neighboring pixels
and doing something like that right uh
so that's the very simple form of
interpolation
um you also find this with video
decompression algorithms that only save
certain frames and try to interpolate
the frames in between uh in pixel space
and
etching in that article suggests that a
chat gbt and language models generally
can be thought of as a kind of blurry
jpeg of the web where they get trained
to compress the web and then at
inference time when you're generating
text with these models it's a form of
velocity decompression that involves
interpolation in the same way and I
think there is
um I think it's a very interesting test
case for intuitions because I think this
this metaphor this analogy
parts of it are pumping the right
intuitions so there is definitely a deep
connection between machine learning and
compression that has long been observed
and studied
[Music]
there is a sense a very real even
technical sense in which
a machine learning model trains on a lot
of text Data like this with network
prediction is compressing information
about the training data
um uh and uh
um you know the the the the fact that
it's able even to do things like uh uh
remember so many facts about the world
that are present in Wikipedia or or you
recite poems uh like uh that are present
in the training data do all sorts of of
strict memorization exercises or
approximate memorization exercises is uh
there's some extent evidence of that
these are models trains on terabytes of
data uh but the actual model just weighs
a few uh you know it's just a few
gigabytes
of data
um so there is compression but the
generative step when you when you use
the model after training to generate
text I think it's it's it's comparing it
to lossy image decompression is pumping
the wrong intuitions because again that
suggests that all it's doing is this
kind of shallow interpolation that
avoids that amounts to a form of uh
um you know approximate memorization
where you have memory you have memorized
some parts of the data and then you're
you you're Loosely interpolating what's
in between so for example in the text
domain maybe it would be something like
you've memorized every other word of the
junkie's poem and then you're kind of
trying to do some shallow interpolation
of the words in between or something
like that
um again simplifying things a bit but
that's not really what's going on here
um uh you you could conceivably use in
fact some people have done this with
image narration model you could use them
as lossy image compression and
decompression algorithms that's a
specific use case for them uh but that's
a very specific use case but in the
normal case when you generate images or
text language models you're doing more
than that and this is where the
um you talked about the inter
distinction between interpolation and
extrapolation it kind of breaks down a
little bit with these models there was
this thing
colleagues that was published a few
years ago about this where you can think
of interpolation in very high
dimensional spaces as equivalent to
extrapolation okay just because uh
um when you have so many dimensions uh
you know the the the the the the kind of
uh
intuitions you have about interpolation
in a specific uh narrow domain don't
really uh hold uh anymore uh so
um even if we leave the Strategic
technical Point aside from that paper
the intuition is that
um you um uh you know there would there
would be a way presumably to
characterize what uh
um language models large language models
and image generation models are doing
when they generate images and text as
involving a form of interpolation but
this form of metabolism would be very
very different from
um what we might think of when we think
of nearest neighbor pixel interpolation
and lossy image decompression
so different in fact that this analogy
is very unhelpful to understand uh what
generative models are doing because
again uh instead of
being analogous to Brute Force
memorization there's something much more
generally novel and generative about the
process of of inferencing these models
yeah that's great because from my own
experience thinking about quantum
mechanics I can verify that the human
mind is not very good at intuitions in
large dimensional Vector spaces like
once you have worn three dimensions we
don't have a very good idea of what's
going on so that's fascinating that once
you get to huge numbers of Dimensions
interpolation and extrapolation begin to
blur together in an interesting way okay
so what I've learned is that there's a
sense in which you know obviously all
these things are work in progress and
that's fine but there is some sense
maybe in which
there is uh as you said semantic
competence in a large language model
there's a sense in which meaning is
really there there's some structure in
there that is that is non-trivial
um and also there's a sense in which
they can be creative or imaginative so I
guess the last big picture question I
wanted to wonder about was can they be
agents in some way can they have goals
uh can I make a contract with a large
language model can I agree that if it
does this thing today I will pay it some
money 10 years from now
um is are those Concepts even sensible
or do we care about them in the context
of these AI models yeah so this is an
excellent question and this is where I
would again invoke the importance of
having this divide and conquer approach
to the description of capacities to
these models
um so indeed I I've suggested and I just
want to make it clear that I'm
suggesting I'm not suggesting language
models and this stand language like
humans do that they have the full-blown
semantic competence of humans very far
from it but they might have some limited
form of of semantic competence they
might have some in some very
deflationary sense some form of of
creativity or imagination in a sense
we've defined now when it comes to goals
this is where I'm much more skeptical
that we can ascribe anything like
intrinsic goals or desires to a language
model this seems like
a category category mistake or at least
there doesn't seem to be any evidence
that there is anything like that in such
a model
um of course a fully developed answer
would not just appeal to intuitions
based on the learning objective of these
models which is Network prediction
because we've we've talked about how
that's not the whole story uh so we
would have to look again at this kind of
mechanistic interpretability work and
would have to have a a more uh
specific operationalized notion of what
having an intriguity goal is and uh what
kind of function or computation it might
involve and whether there is nothing
functionally analogous to this kind of
computation in this in these models
nonetheless
um there is one thing about this model
that is very important to keep in mind
is that they learn from data in a purely
passive way so they get fed this
continuous stream of sequences of text
and they play this next word prediction
game uh that's how they get trained
that's how they learn to encode various
properties of language and then at eight
for inference time after they've been
trained so we said that the models are
now Frozen just meaning that the
internal parameters are no longer being
adjusted the internal knobs inside the
network are not being tuned anymore so
there is no no more training no more
learning then at inference time uh these
Frozen models are uh
still doing this for prediction uh again
on the prompts on the inputs given by
the by by the human uh at no stage in
this process do we have uh an
opportunity for a genuine interaction uh
between the model and the world or
indeed even between the model and the
language on the world I mean if if the
model was trained by uh through dialogue
for example uh even if it's if if it was
trained on text only then there would be
a little bit more of interactivity but
there is no such thing here
um and so
one thing you might you might consider
is that perhaps having something like
intrinsic goals uh require a form of
learning that's a little bit more active
than the way in which these models are
learning that's one possible
consideration uh another one is that um
these models uh as I just mentioned
they're not continuously learning or
continuously continuously adjusting
their internal parameters so once
they're trained they're frozen and then
you can run inference on them so you can
have some
you have some some input flow through
the network uh what we call the forward
pass to the model so again from input to
Output but again that's just a one
directional process uh it doesn't fit
back into the model's internal encodings
internal representations
um so to that extent also you know when
we think of having interesting goals we
think of having something like Dynamic
um goals that are adjusted basis on the
basis of an ongoing
interaction uh with uh certain inputs
and and calibrating our outputs uh and
because these models are not able to
adjust their weights to change the way
in which their response certain inputs
uh you might think also that that
there's a problem in ascribing anything
like an interesting goal there and then
even you know empirically uh people who
are very concerned about AI safety about
this idea that perhaps artificial
intelligence might in the near medium
term perhaps in the longer term uh
become a genuinely threatening
technology uh for uh even the survival
of the human species as a whole uh
people who are very concerned about this
have been looking for early signs of
potentially threatening problematic
behavior in large language models and
there was a recent effort in that
direction from those sponsored by the
company anthropic which is one of the
large new startups working in on
language models that was developed by
people from open AI who who funded a few
years ago and they had this competition
which was about
um what happens when you when you scale
language models so there is one
surprising thing that we've known at
least since gpt3 was unveiled in 2020 uh
which relates to what we talked about
earlier with the beta lesson which is
that scaling these models meaning just
building models that are just have more
parameters you just cram more parameters
into these models more layers more
connections between the units in the
model
um just doing that and training these
models on more data seems to be
sufficient to have breakthroughs in the
performance on certain tasks so unlock
new capacities so people there talk
about emergent abilities
and actually there are a lot of
connections with physics there and
notion of emergence of course and
there's this paper that was published by
opening in 2020 that finds this this
scaling power laws that look at
how scaling the size of the model and
and the amount of data you turn the
model on
leads to these improvements in their
performance and Export prediction so
that's just looking at extra prediction
but in terms of the actual capacity you
also see this these non-linear
improvements when you go past a certain
size suddenly your model starts being
able to solve certain math problems or
being able to explain certain jokes for
example uh being able to do some forms
of Common Sense reasoning you get this
uh non-linear transition phases as you
scale them up and so
anthropic was interested in whether
there are also some inverse scaling
phenomena where scaling the model
instead of just improving their
performance in a in a in a favorable way
in ways that we we care about and we
find are useful might also lead to
either degradation of performance or
lead to unwanted behavior and one of the
behaviors they were interested in is
what people in the alignment AR
alignment literatures people who are
concerned with aligning the future
artificial intelligence systems with
human values to avoid catastrophic
scenarios what they call power seeking
Behavior so will we find that when you
scale language models past certain sizes
they are more prone to uh starting to
display kind of behavior that's to give
the most caricature example would be
something like ignoring the task that
you're asking them to perform and
instead trying to persuade you to train
uh to augment their capacities by
training uh yet a bigger model or
continuing to trade them on even more
data giving them more computational
power or things like that that seems
very science fictional and far-fetched
uh to me and in fact didn't find
anything like that right through this
competition
that would look like an intrinsic goal
to me I mean if if you did find you know
that models would completely ignore the
tasks that you've asked them to do and
instead try to manipulate you into doing
something totally irrelevant and and you
know self-serving quote unquote from the
prescribing perspective of the model
then that would be indeed very alarming
and look very much like in physicals but
I don't think we see any evidence of
that one of the lessons that I've
learned from doing a lot of podcasts uh
with biologists computer scientists
neuroscientists philosophers is that it
really does matter to who we are as
people that biological intelligences are
embodied right that we live in bodies uh
that we get hungry we get bored we have
training From Evolution to try to you
know survive or at least propagate our
genome and so forth and these large
language models don't have anything like
that they don't get bored if I turn on
the computer and I do not ask chat GPT a
question it does not get irritated with
me right but so on the one hand they
don't have that on the other hand it
doesn't seem that hard to put the model
in a robot and let it walk around and
you know punish it if it gets hurt or
something like that and so I don't know
this is not even a question but
something to speculate about
um maybe that's also a kind of
human-like understanding or thinking
that it wouldn't be that hard to
inculcate in an AI model somehow
yes I mean that's uh that's actually
quite interesting because
um there is a lot of research into
bridging this technology with more
embodied forms of intelligent Behavior
Uh one of the the impressive strides
that have been made recently was from
Google they have this project called say
can
um to refer to this idea that uh
this uh models these these systems
they're trying to build would relate
what what is said to what they can do so
really say can relating language to
action in the world and essentially
these are little uh systems that are
embedded in in these little robots
that have this robotic arm and a little
camera uh and on Wheels uh and uh they
use these pre-trained language models to
parse instructions given by humans such
as you know go fetch the Apple in the
kitchen
um and then these models are used to
translate this natural language
instruction into a format that is more
actionable from a robotics perspective
uh like drive to kitchen and then fetch
Apple so you can break and break down
the uh natural language instruction into
a series of more specific instructions
that can be uh parsed in terms of
specific actions and it has a camera
that is plugged to to a vision uh
language model that can relate uh
specific keywords like kitchen or apple
to Landmark in the landmarks in the
environment so bringing all these things
together all these different elements of
the puzzle you can actually build a
system like this
um however the key aspect here of these
systems is that these are not systems
that are trained end to end by
interacting with the world you are just
using a pre-trained model that has been
trained completely passively to process
language and then plugging it onto these
other modules and so there's a perhaps a
you know surprisingly deep question here
about whether
um uh you know the that's this kind of
system is at all useful to think of what
might be happening in human cognition or
animal cognition with interactions
between different domain specific
modules that might not share
might not share the same kinds of
representational formats and might have
an information that is encapsulated
and that do not really overlap in the
same way what there's only some
information is passed along for further
processing and and transformation in a
different format and so on to other
modules or whether this kind of modular
approach to the mind is not is not the
right one and whether we need models
that don't just you know Stitch these
things together
but actually learn from the ground up by
interacting with the world and having a
rich multi-model sorts of information so
that's interesting how you know these
developments actually map onto
long-standing discussions about uh human
so my last question which is completely
unfair because it will probably require
a lot to answer but do you foresee a
time not too far away that we would want
to give rights to AI models whether
ethical rights or legal rights or you
know to at some point say it would be
wrong to turn off this model because
it's just as human as you or I or at
least to share some aspects in common
yeah I think that's uh that's a question
that uh you know has been on some
people's minds lately for a few
different reasons so one of them is we
haven't really talked about this but
people have been asking whether we can
describe any form of sentience or
Consciousness to large language models
or chatbots so the first big story about
this was when this engineer from Google
Blake Lemoine right became convinced
that their internal chatbot called
Lambda was sentient and turns out it was
on the basis of his his own religious uh
beliefs that led it to to a scribe
sentence to that chatbot based on its
Con on the way it was responding certain
questions turns out if you read the
transcripts these are can be considered
very much as leading questions priming
the model to engage in the language game
of sentience as it were and remember
these models have been trained on a lot
of Science Fiction that includes
sentient AI so they are excellent at
creative fiction and then excellent at
playing the role of a certain character
in a story uh whatever that role may be
so
um I would take this kind of story with
a grain of salt and more recently there
has been also something interesting in
in that with more recent models
so that relates to the rights question
and the ethical question because
um many people think in philosophy and I
think that Maps some too intuitions
people have generally that
um
uh Consciousness having conscious
experiences is something that's
intrinsically valuable meaning that uh a
system a being or whether it's an
organism in the system or an artificial
system that has conscious experiences uh
is is uh uh worthy of moral
consideration spatial moral
consideration just by virtue of having
such experiences such that for example
it would be uh wrong ethically to uh
um inflicts pain onto that system or to
perhaps determinate that system and so
on
um so that's one way in which that
relates to morality but you can also
have a view that doesn't even appeal to
Consciousness and think there is a
certain notion of of personhood or
agency uh that can be valid even for
non-conscious systems and that also uh
relates to uh morally uh weighty
decisions uh in a substantive way where
uh it would be wrong to do certain
things to A system that is an agent or a
person that sense so
um these two things connect to the to
the moral question and to the legal
question uh of course although generally
in the legal discussions
um the details of these discussions are
fleshed out uh in with in less
fine-grained uh in those fine-grained
ways uh of course
um so do I foresee that we should
ascribe uh rights to
deep Learning Systems in the near-term
future
um I I don't uh think so because uh well
I worry that doing so uh would have
immediate potentially very nefarious
implications for humans themselves
because as soon as you ascribe right
right to such systems you might find
yourself from a legal perspective in
cases in which
you have to make decisions that in order
to safeguard the rights of these
artificial systems uh might uh bring
harm to humans
whether that's imprisonment of humans or
you know what happens when if you're
humans
a human has turned off an artificial
system uh that you know is deemed worthy
of Rights is that a form of crime is a
form of of murder or something analogous
to it uh do we need to look up that
human and and so on so that's an extreme
example but there might be many more
subtle examples of that
um so I think really you know there was
this recent Opera about this in the L.A
times uh by my colleague
Henry shelvin and Eric streetskibow
um it was a point about relating
sentience and morality and rights and
the point he was making is that we have
a moral imperative not to shred even
lightly into the territory that could
lead to some ambiguity and confusion
about that meaning we shouldn't build
robots that
um could give us our systems artificial
systems that uh could be serious
candidates for uh sentience or
personhood or agency in this morally
weighty sense uh
um and I when I say serious candidates I
mean that you know most the vast
majority of experts would agree that
current language models are uh you know
almost certainly not sentient because
there are various reasons you can invoke
about uh bias properties that seems to
be missing there that all of the leading
uh scientific theories of Consciousness
seem to think are important for
consciousness you can't be 100 sure but
I cannot I also cannot be 100 sure that
you know uh uh a rock uh doesn't have
some degree of symptoms for Prince
psychist maybe not everything
um
uh but uh but you know that might be
also a different kind of sentience that
might not have the same connection
similarity as well so all of these
things are all moving pieces that have
implications but but yeah I think I
think I I do get the impetus to uh try
not to build models that will uh give us
you know serious reasons to think that
there might be sentience because then we
will face a conundrum it's a damn if you
do damned if you don't scenario uh if
you do give them rights on the basis of
you know on the off chance that there
might be sentient and worthy of moral
and legal consideration then you might
end up harming humans and if you're
wrong about the fact that they're
sentient you know that's it's it's it's
it's a huge moral hazard yeah to to take
that step but on the other hand if you
don't ascribe them any rights and
consider them worthy of of uh you know
being at least moral patients
um and if you're wrong about that uh
then you also uh uh it's also a
considerable moral has it so uh perhaps
the best you know the best best
situation is just to try not to get into
that into that place in the in the first
place and trying to build systems that
would give a serious pose in this way
it's fascinating to me that famously
Alan Turing suggested the touring test
right for you know can a computer think
or if you want be conscious uh he was
really he tried to be clear that he was
not talking about Consciousness but
about thinking and he proposed this test
where if you could fool a human into not
being able to tell whether it was
talking to a person or a machine and the
Machine counts as thinking and to me it
seems pretty clear that these large
language models could easily pass the
touring test and as soon as that
happened everyone lost interest in the
touring test because they realized that
that's not actually a very good
Criterion for thinking it's a little bit
more subtle than that so now we're we're
really faced we have a duty now for lots
of reasons both practical and moral I
think to confront these slightly
philosophical questions we're entering
into Uncharted Territory absolutely yes
so just looking at behavior
um in terms of linguistic output for
example is no longer the gold standard
it used to be uh and uh I mean this is
quite interesting even thinking about
about Consciousness you know for a long
time
um
a lot of what you know like all of
Consciousness research with humans has
to rely on verbal reports to some extent
uh there is no way around that and of
course they can confound the results uh
that you get when you try to establish
certain correlations looking for the
neural correlates of Consciousness for
example but there's no way around the
fact that uh the grand Truth for uh
whether a given individual is
experiencing something and what that
individual is experiencing uh generally
comes off always comes back to some kind
of report verbal or non-verbal but some
kind of introspective report or
self-report
um now we have these systems that can
give you indefinite uh uh reports as it
were uh of uh arbitrary uh precision and
detail and they can talk at length about
their feelings uh and we have very good
reasons to think that they are
intrinsically incapable of feeling
anything and that certainly changes
things I mean the challenges our
intuitions uh about Consciousness how it
might relate to uh perhaps not just
language but perhaps also generally to
intelligence but also it's it's
um
it it just uh
um you know turns on its end the the
kind of uh methods we've used to
investigate uh Consciousness in in
humans because here we don't have access
to the Grand truth and uh we are
standing in the dark trying to make
inferences on the basis of uh certain
properties of these systems I think we
still currently have very compelling
empirical reasons to deny them sentence
but again what happens when we don't is
an interesting and alarming question but
full employment for philosophers so
that's a that's a good situation to be
in so Raphael milia thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast thank you
for having me this was a pleasure
[Music]
thank you